es una nueva víctima francesa de
secuestro en el sahel en un vídeo de 21
segundos publicado en redes sociales el
periodista olivier du wei dijo haber
sido secuestrado el 8 de abril en gao
ciudad del noreste de mali a manos del
grupo yihadista jnm ligado a al qaeda el
gobierno francés confirmó su
desaparición aunque evitó hablar de
secuestro y desde reporteros sin
fronteras pidieron trabajar para su
liberación
hacemos un llamado a las autoridades a
que hagan todo lo posible y pongan todos
los medios a disposición para intentar
asegurar su liberación y que eso ocurra
sin más demoras
[Música]
expertos en terrorismo aseguran que no
está claro si fue atraído con falsas
promesas
alguien le dijo que podría realizar una
entrevista con el comandante yihadista
local de la región por eso fue a gao así
que no sabemos si fue arrastrado allí
por un grupo yihadista o por
secuestradores locales que luego lo
vendieron a un grupo yihadista porque
menos justo de leiter
ya digo el llamado grupo de apoyo al
islam y los musulmanes se formó en 2017
cuando cuatro grandes facciones
yihadistas se unificaron bajo la bandera
de al qaeda desde entonces se ha
afianzado en la región malí y el sahel
han estado luchando para contraer la
insurgencia islamista que ha provocado
miles de muertos y cientos de miles de
desplazados allí los extranjeros se han
convertido en objetivos de secuestros
tuvo a es el último francés en ser
tomado como rehén por militantes de
yihad istas en mali desde la liberación
de la cooperante sofía y petrona en
octubre pasado casi cuatro años después
de su secuestro también en gao